my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of this video
hello everyone i'm alana it is time for
another q a this one is a gaming q a
leave questions below they can be gaming
or not and i just like sort them into
the two different q and as i do first
question is from mcwibble and it says
hey elaine i'm just curious if you had
any insight regarding the perfect dark
studio departures i know you're a big
fan of the game and i know you've
mentioned this before hot news look at
us getting on topic so yes for anyone
who doesn't know the initiative is the
uh
well one of the newer studios from xbox
game studios that is currently in the
process of developing a perfect dark i'm
a very big fan of perfect dark
and i don't know that i know anybody
personally who works at the initiative
um but i do actually know
more than one person who has left the
initiative starting a new studio is
difficult that is part one and i don't
want to
um discourage anybody who works at the
initiative in any way but i do feel like
i can offer a little bit of insight and
this is all very anecdotal obviously
i've not experienced any of this
this is just what i've been told from
people who used to work there i don't
want to be inflammatory to them in any
way whatsoever full respect making games
is really really difficult um
but yeah i can maybe share a little bit
more context that i think could
ultimately be helpful so basically the
reports that just came out say that xbox
studio the initiative has lost
approximately half of its main
development team including a handful of
senior employees according to
information from linkedin around 34
staff members left the company in the
last 12 months including game director
dan newberger design director drew
murray and principal world building
julian myers among other senior members
the studio saw multiple exits across
other disciplines with writers directors
engineers and qa staff also leaving in
the last year and some former employees
spoke to vgc saying
the departures were fast and furious and
that the momentum of ongoing projects
was heavily affected of course
especially when a studio is that small
they're already not a very big studio so
if you have key departures it's going to
have a huge impact on game development
uh the report i'm reading which is
gamesindustry.biz says that staff were
frustrated and didn't feel heard on key
issues surrounding development and the
team also said it was surprised at
microsoft's leniency towards the
studio's lack of progress as a result
one former employee said making games is
hard enough let alone when you feel like
you can't get through to people making
the decisions that affect everyone that
is essentially uh
in line with what i have heard from
friends who
did work there
and no longer do um i would say that
they all and it's not a large group of
people by any means i don't want to act
like this is reflective of everybody's
experiences there or anything like that
either um again trying to
speak about this respectfully because i
take no pleasure in them having any
difficulties
it essentially sounds to me like it was
kind of a thing that
is supposedly not uncommon in game
development where
you know one of these people making key
decisions sees a movie on the weekend
that they really like and then they come
into the studio and they go we need to
do this
and then everything just changes
underneath them and nobody's in a
position to say no which definitely
happens that's not like unheard of um
but it was just so specific that that
had been mentioned to me so many times
without me
asking or without me saying like hey i
heard this is this true it was just
offered up so it must be very prevalent
part of the culture
or at least from those people's
perspectives but yeah it it sounds to me
like the main thing was there were
a person or a couple of people who were
able to
wield a lot of creative power um
in a way that was very chaotic they were
kind of making the team adjust and make
changes on the fly based on whatever
caught their fancy
in
the last week again not a difficult
thing to happen um
and certainly not in the games industry
where
you know we take so much inspiration
from other stuff like everybody who
works in video games is a
big old nerd we like movies and tv shows
and we like other games and we're very
passionate about
the worlds that uh we get lost in so i
understand how this kind of thing
happens um
and i think it's also kind of a games
industry problem and again i do need to
mention i could be completely talking
out my ass this is just such a small
group of people that i've had this
conversation with but i do think that
there is an issue in um
broader
games industry not just game development
where
the industry's still very young and
people who have been in it for a long
time just get promoted and they have no
management experience or direction
experience or production experience
they just like were in the right rooms
at the right time and have a lot of
years of doing something but not like
those skills like the skills of working
with a team
or of uh engaging engaging with people
creatively or you know executing on
something that can cost
millions and millions of dollars and
that leads to a lot of
just yeah
leadership
who changes their mind all the time
and very frustrated stuff underneath
them
and things that get delayed and need
production assistance i hope that
everybody at the initiative is doing
well and is enjoying their jobs of
course
um
it does sound like they're all really
passionate about what they're doing and
i guess just sometimes that can be very
frustrating but again i don't know if
that's the bulk of the issue just just
the one that i heard and i do want to
say
game development is hard there are a
million stories that you could write
about
every game that's been developed where
it sounded like everything was on fire
and it wasn't going to ship and it was
completely broken
because it is broken until you ship like
that's how it works but then it comes
together so every studio has a story
that's like this departures are a little
bit different uh though of course we are
you know in a pandemic and it is a brand
new studio it's still figuring out
who slash what it is culturally but yes
ultimately i wanted to say regardless
it's not the end of the world doesn't
mean perfect dark is doomed
everyone has a story like this
and also wow games industry even as an s
side even if it isn't reflective of
what's happening at the initiative at
all please stop promoting people into
positions of leadership that they do not
have
proven people skills and leadership to
manage
probably happens in like kind of all
startup tech culture as well just
you doing something for 10 years doesn't
mean that you have the skills to be a
manager
that's all i'm saying it is time to talk
about keeps keeps is an online
subscription service that helps men keep
their hair there is no magical cure for
boldness but you can prevent hair loss
from happening in the first place the
earlier you take action the more hair
you'll keep that is of course only if
you want to there are so many products
for women for all of their insecurities
i feel like there aren't enough for men
and truth is a lot of men are really
insecure about this so it's all about
self-love but obviously if you're not
interested no shame in it being bold is
awesome too thing that i consider to be
especially important about keeps and
something that i know has been
comforting to the man i know who use
keeps and i do know several is that it
is doctor recommended it is fda approved
with clinically proven treatments to
combat the symptoms of hair loss and you
get 24 7 expert support keeps treatment
plans come with a year of unlimited
doctor messaging which is awesome
they're also really good about getting
you a routine that works for you whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered of course in addition to
the clinically proven treatments keeps
has an award-winning all-natural
thickening shampoo and conditioner
system as well and keeps positions will
help you select the right products and
treatments for your specific condition
and hair goals then your daily supply of
treatment arrives every three months and
at half the cost of a pharmacy so you
don't have to have any awkward doctor
visits in person or wait in lines at the
pharmacy so if you are interested in
doctor-supported fda-approved keeps and
you want to stop hair loss you can get
50 off your first order by going to
keeps.com alana pierce or click the link
in the description that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash alana pierce now back to the
video michael outside great video as
always i'm curious if you usually finish
the many games you play i tend to put
games down and pick them back up which
for me means i don't complete them as
often even if i like them keep up the
great work um
i don't know the percentage of games
that i play that i finish but it
definitely isn't all of them i used to
um not even that long ago stubbornly
finished games even if i didn't enjoy
them but now as a person with a very
demanding full-time job and my own
business which
right now i've been perfectly candid um
i'm doing my best to try to make more
money so that i can
try to support my family while i have a
sick family member seems like it may
become a reality that um i may need to
help out and try to pay for one other
person entirely if i
can
if you see an increase in ads here that
would be why
it is straight up so i can help my
family out um but in any case basically
now i have too many [ __ ] priorities
so if i don't like something i stop
playing it um but i feel like i finish
majority of the games that i play there
are a lot of things that i pick up and
put down some things take me six months
to finish depending on the game there
are things that like i want to play
through really casually there are things
that i know that i won't finish i knew
dying light too that i was probably
never going to finish it i did end up
putting 20 hours in but i knew i wasn't
going to finish it and like elden ring i
don't know if i'll finish because i've
now played it on three separate saves so
i have i have a steam account that is
public intentionally for like all
streaming and content creation purposes
so i played 14 hours on that account and
then i got it on xbox and then i got it
on my private pc account the steam and
now i'm like
and i have to pick one and
you know
i still want to but god it's so long
in any case i don't know the answer i
finished most games that i start um
but it's certainly not all of them and
again i used to but now it's just as
soon as i'm not like absolutely loving
something or if i feel like something's
getting repetitive i just like bow out
and play something else instead
because i don't
there are so many games out too like not
only is it like personal priorities and
like [ __ ] i have to do it's also just
there are so many games why play
something i'm not loving when i could
play other games
took me a long time to learn that
balance that's for sure i had to like
untrain this like weird guilt that i
would have for starting something and
not finishing it but it is gone now like
i said could you comment on or maybe
explain about the game censorship in
australia i understand it's pretty
strict and just find it strange for
example i noticed that rimmel got banned
on steam in australia it's graphically a
very simple 2d game um yeah people ask
me about uh video game censorship in
australia pretty often and i will say
that
your assumptions are exaggerated not you
specifically but for vast majority
people they're like doesn't everything
get banned in australia
and if you're in australia
you'll like barely even really notice it
it's not
it's not as prevalent as it's made out
to be i can't speak to rimworld
specifically but there are a couple of
very specific things that the australian
board will ban games for incentivized
drug use is one of them um i was like so
sure that cyberpunk would get banned but
it didn't so
you know it's not potentially that
sensitive um but that is
i believe australia was the reason that
fallout had to change the name of
certain things to
like stim packs
or uh things have to be med kits instead
of morphine
especially if there's an achievement or
a reward tied to it so if you have a
real world drug or even a fake drug that
seems a little bit too close to home and
there is an incentive or a reward for
using it
that goes against the australian
guidelines second common one generally
i'm against censorship in general but
it's hard to argue against this one in
terms of like i don't feel like i would
want to experience it anyway
is um
sexual assaults interactive sexual
assault so anything where you would
sexually assault or rape somebody again
usually tied to a reward but just in
general any kind of sexual assault if
it's interactive is banned so you could
have it in a cutscene but if you are the
one doing it that is a ban and that
guideline is written pretty specifically
strictly that way so um
an example of that that was pretty
heavily publicized is that the context
doesn't matter right it is literally
just if there's interactive sexual
assault
not allowed
and so the i think it was the first
south park game
the stick of truth um
there's a part in the global release
where you press a button and randy marsh
gets anally probed on an alien spaceship
that is you pressing a button to
sexually assault someone essentially for
a joke it's south park i get that it's a
joke but that doesn't there's no like
part of a government guideline that says
unless it's a joke so that had to be
taken out
and i actually think that what they
replaced it with is much funnier
instead in the australian version
instead of what they considered to be
interactive sexual assault it's
it's this picture of a koala
crying
while a didgeridoo plays in the
background and there's text on screen
that's like wow australia we had to cut
this because of your government
censorship
which again i found to be significantly
funnier than the press button to anal
pro brandy neil valley said how do game
review codes work at a big company like
ign does ign have a steam account that
everyone plays games from or do you add
the game to your personal account if
it's your personal account you get to
keep the game
so
it depended on like the publisher and
the relationship that you had with them
like i had some publishers who would
just give me codes directly and then
yeah i would add them to a personal
account
which is obviously what happens for me
now ign does not have a shared steam
account um
actually funhouse had a
shared
steam account where every single game
was unlockable for free which is nuts
like i guess it was like this old
system that they had maybe from
machinima or something where every
single game
you could just get on steam
for free i'm pretty sure that's how it
worked at least it was nuts like so of
course we were all using that account to
buy things because
everything was there
it was amazing unfortunately a certain
employee
took it with them and changed the
password when they were removed from the
company which is a real dick move it's a
really shitty thing to do to all the
people who work there who like needed
that account to make content but ign
never had one of those so no it was that
publishers would allocate like a certain
amount of keys they would have available
and then it was usually given to the
people who were
on podcasts or needed it for news always
wikis the wikis would always get codes
and then yeah you'd add it to your
personal account and yes you would you
would keep it the code the game wouldn't
remove itself from your account
but
it's was always used for work they
wouldn't give you a code if you didn't
have some outlet to speak about
the thing or benefit the company it
wasn't like you were just getting
games to play for fun in your spare time
i mean you were but there was an
expectation that if you got a code you
would make content with the code unless
there was like such a huge excess of
them that that didn't apply rassy
shackle but said hi alana do you think
living on the west coast has made it
easier to get a video game writing job
also do you think game studios lean more
towards office work rather than working
from home
um
i mean i very intentionally moved to the
west coast of the united states from
australia so that i could get jobs in
the games industry i did that on purpose
like i moved when i was
21 and had
not enough money to even buy a mattress
i had nothing but i did it so that i
could be where the industry was for the
highest chances of being employed
and obviously that's why i stay so do i
think that's that's made it easier
definitely yes but um it's not like i
lived on the west coast first i moved to
the west coast
to be able to get those jobs do i think
game studios lean more towards office
work rather than working from home uh
would depend on the game studio but um
my stance
personally going forward because of a
number of like just health issues that i
have that are so much more manageable
now that i have a little bit more
freedom is that i will straight up never
go back to working in an office
full-time i will not do it
i would pass on a job that would ask me
to do that and obviously that's like a
super
privileged position that i'm in to be
able to do that but i know that i need
it for my own health
the last time i was working in an office
full-time i was fainting on a frequent
basis i was so unwell i was like a husk
of a human and not having to be in an
office all the time has meant that i
could just do a much better job of
looking after myself so
my health is the best it's been in a
really long time um so that's definitely
my stance and there are a lot of games
that uh
work with people who aren't even in the
same country where writing's concerned
it would be difficult to be like on the
writing team you know treated full time
but you can get writing assignments
contract that um would just straight up
be sent to you and then you just send it
back and those they do those
internationally so it's definitely not
impossible but to directly answer your
question you know i moved to california
to work in the games industry because i
knew that it would
make it easier
and it did
i think
[Music]
that is it from me today everyone thank
you all so much for watching
thank you to keep sponsoring the video
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]